- Welcome to re:Invent 2025.
My name is Umesh Sampat.
I'm the director for
training products at AWS.
I'm also enlightened to
welcome my good friend,
Julio Blanco Perez from Santander.
He's gonna share the stage with me today
and talk about AI skills.
So, Julio, if you wouldn't mind
kinda introducing yourself.
So, he's the acting CTO at Santander.
I'm really excited about the
portion of the presentation
that Julio is actually gonna deliver today
'cause it brings home
a lot of what we wanna talk about.
- Thank you, if you can hear me too,
everything's all right.
Thank you, Umesh, for having me.
I really thrilled to be here to share
what we've been doing
for the last two years
in partnership with AWS.
- Yeah, no, exciting times ahead.
Like, I was very thrilled
about what Santander was able to do,
how they've been able to leverage
a lot of the, like, mechanisms
that we'll talk about
in the products that we've built at AWS,
particularly around
upskilling the workforce
and they see some really
practical, outstanding results.
So, looking forward to Julio
kind of talking a little bit about that
towards the second part
of the presentation.
So let me kinda start with what is...
like, let me kind of talk a little bit
about what we'll cover today.
Largely, we're actually
gonna talk a little bit
about the challenges and the opportunities
that exist from AI,
and particularly around AI upskilling
and why it's important
both for individuals
as well as for organizations.
Next, we'll actually
cover how Skill Builder,
how we've evolved Skill Builder,
and how we continue to actually
make Skill Builder available
with AI-powered experiences
that actually help you achieve
the AI transformation and AI skilling
that you're looking for at scale.
And then to bring it home,
I'll hand the mic over to Julio
who will walk us through
Santander's story.
So we'll spend about 20, 25 minutes
just talking about the problem space
and the approach that we're taking.
And then, we'll actually land
with the practical aspect
of Santander's story.
So let me kinda start with a few stats,
some data just to kind of land
the challenge in front of us.
According to the World Economic Forum,
the jobs report in 2025,
40% of core job skills
are expected to change by 2030.
Just reflect on that for a second.
That's nearly half,
the world's population is
gonna see changes in skills.
It's really interesting
challenge for all of us
and ahead of us, particularly
around upskilling.
The other statistic that I wanna share
is AWS ran a research study
across several different organizations.
Most of these organizations
that we talked to,
92% of them said
they plan to have AI projects
either in the works
or in production by 2028.
However, three out of four or 75% of them
said that they can't find
the talent that they need.
So there's this really interesting gap
of ambition and capability.
And this is actually really interesting.
I see some heads nodding in the crowd.
This is a really interesting time
for all of us around AI upskilling.
The other aspect of this challenge
that makes it a bit more interesting
and complicated in some ways
is this idea of half-life
or skills half-life.
According to Forbes,
this was an article
published in Forbes in 2024.
I still think it's relevant,
so we've included it on the slide.
The half-life for jobs in the 1980s
was about 10 years.
In 2024, that was about four.
And the Forbes article
through the Stanford study
shows that that half-life for skills
could actually be just two years
in the next two to four years.
So what's happening is AI skills
are evolving pretty quickly,
and constant continuous learning
is essentially going to be required,
no longer a nice to have.
So this is the other aspect
of what we're actually seeing
in terms of how the skills
are actually evolving.
Now, we've talked about challenges so far.
Let's actually talk a bit
about the opportunities.
A study that was done
by Skillsoft IT Skills and Salary Report
indicates that individuals
that possess AI skills
tend to make 47% higher in compensation.
So if you can actually be decisive
about taking control of your career
and your AI skilling
and essentially bring AI skilling
as a part of your
professional development,
you have the opportunity
to tap into that premium.
It's not a small descent,
lift in terms of compensation.
So there's a really
interesting mix of challenge
and opportunity that we see
from a AI skilling standpoint.
So let's talk a little bit
about how the modern learner's
journey is evolving as well.
Obviously, technical
skills and core skills
have been part of
learning for a long time.
That's not changing.
The foundational aspects
continue to still be incredibly relevant.
However, complementary to
those foundational aspects
are human-centric skills.
And generative AI and AI technologies
are actually making it a lot easier
for products like ours, frankly,
that can bring human-centric skills
to complement the
technology-focused skills.
So human-centric skills,
particularly like communication,
critical thinking, relationship building,
these are all integrated into
learning experiences today.
And we'll talk a little bit
about how Skill Builder has evolved
to support these capabilities.
The other aspect that is changing
quite rapidly is this idea
that people don't have time
professionally, personally.
And so taking out two,
three days from your work,
some people can still do it.
But oftentimes, micro learning
is becoming much more of the norm.
It's like 15 minutes,
I have 15 minutes to learn something,
I have a couple hours to learn something.
And so this idea of
transactional learning,
making it fun and engaging
is the other aspect
of what we're actually seeing
the individual's learning journey
and how it's evolving.
So let me reframe the
learning cycle, if you will.
We obviously think of the learning cycle
through the learn lens,
where you're learning concepts,
you practice it to
reinforce your learning,
you prepare for credentials or exams,
and then you basically get,
let's say an AWS certification.
And that's traditionally been sort
of the waterfall approach.
However, what we're actually observing
is that the learn and practice phase
are getting smaller and
much more continuous.
So you learn bursts of concepts,
you practice them in the same experience,
and that actually helps
you go back and forth.
You can actually do this
micro learning thing
back and forth multiple times.
You learn a concept, you practice it.
You learn the next
concept, you practice it.
If you need to reinforce
the first concept,
you learn, you can do that.
This also helps you
in the context of what you're working on.
So while you're actually
solving a problem,
you say, yeah, I need 30 minutes.
I'm actually gonna go learn
a concept, practice it.
And then, come back to my
real work that I'm doing.
And so this idea of micro learning
is becoming much more of the norm.
And it supports this idea
of continuous learning that we saw
previously in terms of
one of the challenges.
Once you've amassed a body of knowledge
and you've accumulated these concepts
across a single domain,
you can actually go
into the prepare phase.
And then, once you actually
have prepared for your exams,
you can get credentials.
So these AI-powered personalization
is really actually helping
a lot of our learners.
So let me dive a little bit
deeper on the learn phase.
AWS Skill Builder provides
330 or so resources and ever-growing
to actually help you grow your AI skills.
And those are a combination
of technical skills
where you learn core concepts
or you can actually go deeper
if you're interested in
learning deeper concepts with AI
as well as human-centric skills.
And so we've actually built products
that bring those experiences together
where you can learn, you can practice,
and you can actually practice both,
technical skills and
human-centered skills.
I'll talk a lot about these products
that you see on the
slide here where it talks
about AI-powered immersive
learning experiences
like SimuLearn or Meeting Simulators.
So I'll cover those in
in a bit more detail
as we walk through the presentation today.
Let's talk about the practice phase.
If you're interested in building a role
or industry expertise,
we have a series of products
that actually help you do that.
For example, top left,
you see Cloud Quest.
Cloud Quest is a 3D game product
where you can actually
learn cloud concepts
in essentially a game-based
learning experience.
You can try out a variety of AWS services
in the same game,
and you can actually learn
concepts, practice it,
solve the quest, go to the next one,
and so on.
So these experiences around
micro learning are built in
to essentially the Skill
Builder product set.
Similarly, if you're just
interested in reading,
like looking at labs,
you can actually go and
practice a lot of the concepts
within Builder Labs or Jam sessions.
These are, again, products that help you
practice what you've actually learned
in a real AWS environment.
You can develop communications
and human-centric skills
through products like Meeting
Simulator and SimuLearn.
And then, the other aspect
of what we've actually
learned with practice
is group-based learning,
where you can actually use Card Clash,
which is essentially a game-based product
that helps you go head
to head with individuals
and you can actually learn
in a group-based format.
So again, these learn and
practice experiences are built
right into the product set
with AWS Skill Builder.
Let's take a look at some of
the products that I mentioned
slightly in more depth as we
walk through the presentation.
So Cloud Quest generative AI practitioner,
it's primarily designed
for someone interested
in foundational skills.
But essentially, you
are in a 3D virtual city
and you take...
you're actually learning
from guided experiences
that are built into the game.
You go through recommendations
and you actually try
out your recommendations
in real-world AWS environments
right there in that experience.
So it's bringing learning and practicing
all within the entire-
in essentially the same experience.
And so you learn and you
get hands-on experience
with Amazon Bedrock, with SageMaker,
with Q Developer,
and the list goes on.
You can also learn
about essentially foundational
models, prompt engineering,
you can learn about RAG
implementation concepts and so on.
And this is an ever-growing
list of capabilities
that we're adding continuously.
I mentioned with Skill Builder,
we have 330 such resources.
We continuously add to them
as new technology comes out.
If you're not quite friendly
to a 3D-based game type learning format,
we have SimuLearn.
Essentially, SimuLearn is mimicking
a real-world scenario for you.
So it's a simulated learning experience
where you engage with
AI-powered virtual agents.
And essentially, you are
gathering requirements,
you're developing
architectural recommendations,
you're providing essentially
proposals to AI agents.
And these agents are
actually providing you
feedback on two things:
One is the technical skills
that you're learning,
the other is the human-centered skills,
particularly around communication.
So you get the entire feedback
right within the context
of the simulated learning environment.
So it's a nifty experience.
And what we've noticed
is like when we look at engagement data,
particularly with Cloud
Quest and with SimuLearn,
our engagement numbers with
learners is incredibly high
when compared to traditional
digital learning formats
because you're actually bringing
these two experiences together
in a micro learning format.
And by the way, it's perfect
for either you're starting off
or you're actually developing
advanced architectural concepts.
We have a ton of different
courses in SimuLearn
that actually specifically cover
generative AI architecture plans.
Next I wanna talk about Meeting Simulator.
This is a super interesting launch.
We launched this product not too long ago,
November 12th, just last month.
And this is actually primarily focused
on developing human-centered skills.
So it simulates real-world,
high-stakes conversations
through voice or text.
So again, it's fascinating.
This is where we've actually leveraged AI
and generative AI technologies
to improve and make our
learning products better,
but also we're actually leveraging them
to teach AI and AI concepts.
So in this case,
you can actually simulate
practical scenarios.
So for example, you can simulate scenarios
where you're discussing cost
conversations with the CFO
and the agent persona goes back and forth
and gives you real-time feedback
on how you're communicating.
So if you're essentially preparing
for a technical sales role
or you're preparing for
stakeholder type roles,
this product would actually
be perfect for you.
Next, once you've amassed
sufficient body of knowledge
where you've gone back and
forth with micro learning,
you can prepare for certification exams.
And we've made preparation
for the certification exams quite easy.
You get to know your exam,
you refresh your skills,
you can review and practice
through exam-style questions.
And then like essentially self-assess,
are you ready to take an
AWS certification or not?
These certifications tend
to be several hours long
with multiple choice
questions back and forth.
So going through a preparation phase
actually helps individuals.
Now, before I dive into
what are the specific
AI/ML certifications that we
have published or launched,
I wanna talk a little bit
about why certifications are important.
Remember the 47% compensation
bump that I talked about?
Knowing the skills is one thing,
but having the credentials on your resume
helps you overcome
because it actually validates
for prospective employers
that you actually know the AI skills.
The other aspect is and
these are some stats
that I'll kinda share more broadly,
it's about a million
unique individuals today
over a million that
possess AWS certifications,
and some of them possess
multiple certifications.
So it's actually quite
popular amongst individuals,
but also frankly amongst
prospective employers.
We actually ran a study
and we asked organizations,
do these certifications mean a lot?
And I know Julio will talk
a little bit about this
with Santander as well.
But interestingly enough,
91% of the organizations we spoke to
said that having AWS-certified staff
increased innovation in their companies.
Also 90% plus
said that they were able to reduce costs.
So we see both innovative
and productivity gains for organizations
when you actually are hiring individuals
with AWS certifications.
Now let me talk a little bit
about the four
certifications that we have.
We have in a total of
about 12 certifications.
AI Practitioner Foundational,
it's sort of validating
that you know foundational concepts in AI.
Machine Learning Engineer Associate
is actually really
validating that you know
essentially machine learning
and deep learning concepts;
model tuning, those types of things.
Data Engineer Associate is
a really interesting one.
Oftentimes to get agentic
applications built,
data and data pipelines
are incredibly important.
And so data engineer
associate helps validate
essentially the data
pipelines are in place
and your set up to build
those agentic applications.
And then, we're proud to announce
on November 18th the beta version
of Generative AI Professional.
So this is a developer
certification that helps validate
that you can actually
build agentic applications.
So we're excited with
these certifications.
And just so you know,
machine learning engineer
and data engineer have
been around for some time,
but they've been updated
with more recent questions
and essentially skills that
validate agentic capabilities.
We've also heard from
a lot of our learners
that taking these
certifications can be onerous.
And so we are excited to, again, announce
that we launched microcredentials.
These microcredentials are
actually incredibly valuable
'cause they actually
provide real-time assessment
in real AWS environments.
Unlike certifications that have Q&A
where they're testing your knowledge,
these microcredentials actually
validate hands-on skills.
So your assessments are actually
within AWS environments,
and you can prove that not only you know
the concept in theory,
but you actually know how to operate
those services at scale.
Currently we have two that
we launched on November 12th:
AWS Agentic AI Demonstrated
and AWS Serverless Demonstrated.
These complement our
certifications really well.
And they actually go hand in hand
with the concept of micro learning.
So now imagine you learn,
you practice, you validate,
and you do it in smaller chunks
and you rinse and repeat
and you're essentially amassing
a body of knowledge continuously.
So that's kind of a bit of a recap
of the individual journey
where we talked about learn and practice
getting closer one another.
Preparation for exams
becomes part of the journey
after you've actually gone back and forth
with learn and practice.
With microcredentials, you can do
a certain percentage of validations
in that learn and practice phase.
And then, validate actually is either
through microcredentials
or certifications.
So that's your path as an
individual to AI career
and hopefully the success
that comes behind it.
Now, now that we've
talked about individuals,
let's actually talk about what
happens within organizations.
One of the most powerful ways
we believe to build culture
is through collaborative
team-based learning.
And Julio will talk about this,
like, I'm really excited about his talk,
where he brings this together.
But essentially, we've
built a series of products
that actually help collaborative
team-based learning.
Remember I mentioned Cloud Quest,
which was essentially the
3D game for individuals?
There's Cloud Quest
tournaments for organizations.
So it's really open-ended.
You learn, you solve problems together
in real-world AWS environments as teams
competing against one
another in a healthy way
and you actually get the
engagement at the team level.
AWS Jams have been around for some time.
These are open-ended lab-based problems
where teams get together
and actually solve real-world challenges.
There's leaderboards, you can
actually see who's doing what.
You can set up your own
challenges that you'd like.
So again, super interesting way
to actually get engagement
across your teams.
AWS Card Clash,
it's a game-based app that we've built.
You can actually test your knowledge
head to head with other individuals.
It helps to learn,
but it also helps to
reinforce what you've learned.
Escape Room is really,
really popular one too.
Escape Rooms are actually group-based
certification exam preparations.
So if you've been in a
physical escape room,
it's a similar concept, it's virtual.
And you can essentially go,
you can actually solve problems together,
learn for actually certifications.
And once you actually get
from one room to another,
you're actually doing it in a
group-based learning format.
So it's fun to kinda
get prepared for an exam
in a group-based format.
And then lastly, Skill Builder Trivia.
It's another way to
actually reinforce knowledge
through large-scale team competition.
Now a lot of these formats
are actually available at re:Invent.
So I'll talk a little bit
about exactly where you'll find them.
So if you really want to
experience them firsthand,
they're present across several venues
here at re:Invent '25.
Let me talk about one more launch
that we had on November
12th called Cohort Studio
before I hand the mic over to Julio.
But Cohort Studio, essentially,
one of the feedback that we had received
from a lot of our customers,
and particularly in partnership
with Santander even,
essentially bringing a lot
of these experiences together
in multiple of these experiences,
like SimuLearn or, you know, Card Clash,
or Jams, et cetera
together in a single experience
was a problem for a lot of our customers,
particularly when they
were actually looking
to launch team-based learning
within their organization.
So with Cohort Studio,
anyone can launch a cohort program
in less than 15 minutes.
It's AI-powered.
You can pick and choose the
experiences that I talked about
and you can drive engagement
and teamwork and recognition.
Whether you're trying to
organize a certification exam
or you're actually trying to
get AI skills bootcamps ready
or you're actually looking
at team competitions,
you can actually do that in Cohort Studio.
So we're very excited about this launch
and I have to thank like Santander
to, like, helping us actually figure out
and visualize what this
product would look like.
With that, let me hand
the mic over to Julio.
I'm really excited.
He's the acting CTO,
again, of Santander Bank
and he's gonna walk you
through how Santander took over
some of the mechanisms and
products that we've talked about
and made it real and actually
ran a program at scale
in a financial services company.
Thank you, Julio.
- Thank you, Umesh.
Hello, everybody again.
I will first try to introduce Santander
because I don't know if
everybody knows Santander.
But it's a bank of 180 years of history
and that is really relevant
when we are talking
about cloud and AI
for scaling training
because we are a traditional bank
and we are a global bank
and we are dealing with
products that deals
with individual from individuals
to huge corporations.
So we have a portfolio product that cover
nearly everything that you
think about in banking,
probably we have a
product that cover that.
We have nearly 200 million customers
and nearly 2 billion
euros in managed assets.
And also we are partnered
with AWS since 2018
to scale the way that we deal
with our customers.
We're like to introduce ourself
as a digital bank with branches.
So technology is embedded
and should be embedded
in everything that we do,
but we also think that
branches gives a lot of power
and a lot of reach depending on the people
that we are dealing with.
So really engaging this hybrid approach
between a full digital bank
and a traditional bank
that has relationship through branches.
And even if we are a
digital global company,
we are focusing here of a program
that we launched two years ago in Brazil.
So everything from here
to the end of the
presentation is Brazil-based.
And we are trying to think
about how to you scale it
throughout the company.
So what's AWS Level UP?
I'm taking some words
from Umesh' presentation
that traditional learning
is not working anymore.
At least from our point of
view in a big enterprise,
launching lots of mandatory
training does not scale.
People don't want to be
three days in a classroom
with people of different levels.
So in the end, you don't
get the things that you want
that everybody on board that
everybody want to be learning.
But we also don't really see
that we are there in terms
of you as a employee,
manage your own training
program by yourself,
getting into Skill Builder,
trying to build everything that you need
to be able to be certified.
So when we thought
about how we will be scaling our program,
we mixed everything together.
So Level UP,
it's just like a progression game,
but we have rules,
we have paths,
we have accountancy,
we have three-to-nine months expectation
depending of the
complexity of the courses.
And we designed it with
AWS because, you know,
they know a lot
about their own platform
and we mix our needs
and our paths for certification
with their knowledge.
So more or less, how it works?
When you get onboarded,
you are assigned with a study group
that more or less fits your knowledge
and what certification
you're gonna get.
And then, you're also
onboarded on Skill Builder.
So you have a clear path
of where your next train,
but you are also able
to do it by yourself.
You can get courses from
outside of your learning path.
But what I'm saying,
you have a cadence.
People around you,
asking questions about the next training,
asking if you got...
you are up to the training path.
So everybody is trying,
is pushing the other
members of the team forward.
We started seeing that
this is not something
that we planned for, right?
We started seeing along the way
that people started pushing each other
because of the badges,
because of it's not a real gamification,
we don't have a leadership,
but you can see how other people
in your study group are going.
So in the end, you have
a little gamification.
We didn't want a full
gamification without leadership,
a champion in the end
because we wanted everybody to go on board
and everybody to put in pushing
for the training to go over.
And we also,
and I will be explaining you some slides,
you know, in a few slides,
we thought about how we were doing
to have something different
for the people that went to the end
and got certified.
We created what we call an AWS experience
with kind of re:Invent
and our certified people
can have a VIP lounge.
Lots of things over there.
They are different T-shirt,
they can show all over the organization
that they are certified.
So they're kind of our VIP guys
for the party.
So what I'm saying,
we created a framework.
So we created that kind
of progression system
throughout the process.
So even we have lots of different parts
for AI certifications,
for cloud practitioners,
for solution architects.
They have different paths,
but in the end everything goes
through the same way,
through the same road.
So different study groups,
we have a hard schedule.
So if you are going to be certified,
not certified, but going to the end
of the training in three months,
we schedule several
trainings along the way,
but we expect you
to go forward on your own self-paced,
but you will be, you know...
Everybody will see that you
are not doing your training
with your own group,
which was something
really, really interesting.
And what are we saying?
More effective communication
was starting to come up
through all the teams
that this is something that created
a kind of speed of community
that didn't have before.
We had other ways of training people.
We had lots of AWS training.
We had invested a lot in training,
not only with AWS,
but we wouldn't get the same results
until we got up this mixed system
that, I think, that we
reach the sweet spot
between mandatory things
and feeling free
to go after knowledge.
So let me switch a little bit over here.
If you are a tech worker
in Santander, Brazil,
something from someone
for our development teams,
what would you see when you start
your journey, you're onboarded?
You register in our portal,
in our learning portal.
It's available for many other things
and you are enrolled
inside AWS Skill Builder.
So that's, you know, the
more traditional thing.
You'll go over there,
you are onboarded.
But then other things along the path
are assigned to you.
You are assigned, for example,
for a cloud west tournament
and people go together,
play together to resolve
all that different scenarios.
We also have training
sessions from Skill Builder
that are more or less sync
for that particular team.
We also have traditional
what we call outlaws in Portuguese,
a big classroom,
which is the sync part of the training.
Everybody goes there for some day
for some specific topic.
So we are not abandoning
traditional learning
because there are some
people from the team
that don't really get that
micro learning strategy.
They're not there.
So as we want everybody to go forward,
we mixed everything up.
Then, we got everybody
to practice their sums.
You use SimuLearn,
they use other platforms
to simulate the sums.
And then, we are ready, they pass.
We have some evaluations
for all the results they got.
They are given the AWS voucher
to go for the certification.
And then when everything is finished,
as we are saying,
it's a fixed timeline.
At the end of the three
months, six months,
or nine months project,
we have a closing session
when we have some pricing,
giveaways from devices
or whatever that only the
people that got certified
can get the prices.
So it's the last mile gamification.
It's not really big money,
but you know that everybody
wants to go in the stage
and get the device.
That was from the point of view
of a person.
But from the point of
view of the organization,
you can really see that we got thousands
of people onboarded
in our training,
and hundreds of them
being able to complete,
even to certify,
we had nearly 120 certifications
when we began the this project.
So from 100 to 700, it's huge.
It's a huge-
and we also saw
that kind of change
in how training
was being misunderstood
because training was
that mandatory training,
everything the HR wanted people to do
and your manager will go after you
if you didn't complete your training
during that period.
And we started seeing
more people going together
and discussing about how to get the best
from the tooling
that we are giving to them
and start seeing
that complete tooling being
used in other use cases,
that special teams wanted
more advanced classes, ILT classrooms
because they something
in their path was not covered
and they really wanted that
for their day-to-day job.
So it really changed
the way that we manage training
throughout the last two years.
And as I was saying,
was three years ago,
some of our executives
were coming back from re:Invent to Brazil,
and they just start saying,
why don't we try to organize
and experience like
re:Invent there in Brazil?
So we partnered with AWS,
another and another partners of us.
And we started re:Invent,
which Santander AWS experience,
which what I'm saying,
it explode the way that
we felt about training
because we have 2021
last time.
In October, we got 21
talks level 200, level 300,
as we have lots of people trained,
we didn't have to have L100 sessions.
We tried to push to rise the bar
and have more quality paths.
We have different paths.
We have AI path, we have
databases path, architecture,
so I cannot say it's the same as re:Invent
because there are lots of things together,
but we have three to four
different talks at the same time.
We also, this year, we
also got the DeepRacer
inside our, in the
middle of our open space,
so the teams that won for the final
got a lot of public throughout the office
because everybody was
in the same building.
So, you know, we also got escape rooms
and exam preparations
through the three days.
So escape room is usually digital.
We got everybody in the same room
and try to get together
to go to manage to exit.
We make some jokes about that we are going
to close the door,
and they are only going out if they can.
You can't really finish the challenge.
So what I'm saying is and in the end,
we also got a big party,
but I said the people that were certified
are the ones that go in the VIP session
that was in the middle of the parties.
So they have different things,
different booth, whatever,
whatever we thought about
having people gamified thing
without having to create a leaderboard
because if you are useful
in a gamification program,
only the ones that are in
the front are really engaged,
but get in the middle and get
in the end, you lose them.
We wanted everybody on board.
So that's what, even in the
last day, if you got certified,
you go there with your certification
even it's not in the system,
people got the T-shirt
and go into the party.
And that gives us something like this.
As more people got trained, cloud and AI,
we can do things in an easy
way that they wouldn't before.
So we got a problem inside
of our advising organization.
They got stuck trying to
have the correct pitch
for our customers.
They spend more time
preparing the conversation
than having that conversation
with our customers.
So we helped also with help AWS
and we got some stack.
We use AWS stack to get
everything together,
but we transform,
change completely the
way our advisors works.
Now they spend nearly
30 seconds to one minute
to prepare that pitch
because we got everything prepared
for them in our knowledge base,
so all the products of
the Vanguard catalog there
with a relative returns, risk, whatever,
and they can adapt the pitch
for more depth conversation
for that kind of client.
For other clients, it's a
not so deep conversation
and we need a more formal approach
so they can tune many
things on the project.
And the results, you
can see it already there
and I'm passing through all the results,
but we increase nearly 1.2 times increase
in customer contact.
And not only that that
it's just a project,
but it was our first initiative
that went through, you know,
a compressed space of time.
We experimented it, we launched it,
and changed completely the
way one of our main areas
of growth in Brazil is using their time,
so trying to wrap up everything.
We truly believe that there's a transition
to a new way of training inside companies,
especially big ones
that are more mandate-based tradition
of dealing with learning.
We believe that lifelong learning is here
to be here forever.
But we also recognized
that our team was not ready
for a self-pa-
I don't know if some time,
they will be ready for a
full self-paced experience.
So that's was our way of mixing
some things from the past,
like we are 180-years history bank
with top-notch technology
like Skill Builder
to be able to have everything together.
And I'm gonna say,
so I will thank you Umesh
for having that time
to share our story.
And I give the word to you.
- Oh.
Thank you so much Julio.
What an amazing story, like,
just look at how a project,
and then look at some of the outcomes
both in terms of their learning
and how they accomplish the skills,
but also how they applied those skills
in a production context within
their business application,
so super exciting story.
I want to thank Julio for
joining me on on stage today.
So we're towards the end of
our presentation somewhere,
another two more minutes,
and then we're happy to
basically take questions.
In terms of next steps,
here for individuals,
you have access to over
1000 learning resources.
For individuals, you can
go to Skill Builder at AWS,
there's also 330 plus trainings on AI,
you can launch them today.
For organizational leaders,
upscale your workforce at scale.
A lot of these capabilities
that we talk about exist
today in Skill Builder.
Some AI learning spotlight options here,
so if you wanna take a few minutes
to just grab a screen print.
Essentially, there's
Generative AI Learning Plans
for Decision Makers.
There's Generative AI
Learning Plans for Developers
that includes the practical aspects,
Quick Suite Learning Plan,
Agentic AI Learning Plan.
So there's several
different learning options
across the 330, we've just picked a few
to highlight up here.
And I wanna kind of end
our presentation today
with get building agreement.
You can actually take your
AWS cloud AI expertise
to the next level, just
in your mobile app,
in mobile app,
you can plug in training and certification
and it'll show you a variety of these.
And many of these actually
don't require registrations,
you can just walk in.
So you can take boot
camps, spotlight labs.
There's essentially
the gamified challenges
that we've talked about, AWS Jam sessions,
SimuLearn, Escape Room, et cetera.
There's breakout sessions
throughout the conference.
And the trivia app that we talked about,
if you take shuttle buses between venues,
you can actually see it
in the shuttle buses.
So we've tried to bring in a
lot of the learning experiences
right within the conference this year.
So really excited in terms
of what we have to offer.
Hopefully, the session was useful
to kind of talk about the shift,
A, we talked about the challenges,
the opportunity in front of us.
We also talked about
the shift in learning,
continuous being much more of,
not no longer nice to have,
but much more of a requirement
given how quickly the
technology is evolving.
And then, the product
set that we're building
and customers like
Santander are able to use
and personalize it to their needs.
So hopefully, the session was helpful,
please leave us some feedback.
We're happy to take questions.
Logistically, what we were told was,
we're actually gonna walk
over in that area back there.
We have about 10 minutes.
Julio and myself will be there
for at least 10 or 15 minutes.
Happy to take questions,
I don't know how the format would work
with the headphones on,
so we're gonna venture over in that area
and happy to talk to folks.
Thank you so very much,
enjoy the conference.
(audience applauding)